foreign
good morning everyone uh welcome to this
meeting of mid-suffolk District Council
cabinet I am councilor Harry Richardson
Deputy leader of mid-suffolk District
Council and I'm chairing this meeting
today
uh may I remind you of some domestic
Arrangements uh please ensure that
microphones are turned off when not in
use please do not interrupt other
speakers or hold separate conversations
whilst others are speaking
if you are attending the meeting to
speak and persistently interrupt the
meeting you may be asked to leave please
ensure that mobile phones are on silent
or Switched Off and finally we will not
be using e-voting it for this meeting as
there are some problems with the
model.gov app so we will be voting by a
simple share of hands
I'd like to remind everyone present that
this meeting will be broadcast live to
the internet and will be capable of
repeated viewing the whole of the
meeting will be filmed except where
there are confidential or exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
filmed and by entering this meeting as a
speaker you are also consenting to being
recorded by the council and to the
possible use of those images and sound
recordings for webcasting and or
training purposes
the council members of the public and
the Press May record film photograph or
broadcast this meeting when the public
and the Press are not lawfully excluded
can I move to the agenda please item one
apologies for absence
thank you chair we have received
apologies from um Council Susie Morley
councilor Jessica Fleming and Council
David
thank you very much item number two to
receive Declarations of pecuni other
registerable or non-registerable
interests by members are there any to
declare
nope
item number three paper MCA slash 22-5
to confirm the minutes of the meeting
held on the 6th of June 2022 are there
any points regarding the accuracy of the
minutes
nope could I have a proposer please
councilor flackman uh and a seconder
please councilor Gould uh in that case
by where the simple share of hands all
those in favor
that is unanimous thank you
moving on to item number four to receive
a notification of petitions in
accordance with the council petition
scheme
received
item five questions by councilors
none received
check item six matters referred by the
overview in scrutiny or joint audit and
standards committees
there are no matters referred to
thank you very much item seven the
forthcoming decisions list are there any
comments
nope in that case we move on to item
number eight paper MCA slash 22-6 the
general fund financial outturn report
for
2021-22 and I will now invite the
cabinet member for finance to introduce
the report because the Whitehead
uh thank you chairman um I'm pleased to
introduce report
MCA 22 6 on the general fund Financial
out to 2122 so we're closing out the
year with a significant surplus of
1.208 million which is nearly 20 percent
of our council tax preset for the year
and to my mind this reinforces our
decision to freeze our precept for the
current year and potentially Beyond
despite the ever-growing inflatory
situation in which we find ourselves
but having said that I feel it is
important that we're all aware of the
particular narrative that sits behind
the Surplus in 2122 and the
circumstances that have contributed to
it
the main reasons for this India's
Surplus are consistent with what we said
at end of quarter three the largest
constituents being additional planning
income and staff understands
we need to be mindful of the context of
the budget setting for 2122 and where we
were when we set the budget in the
winter of 2020 we are once again in
lockdown and we set our income levels at
that time through a somewhat pessimistic
lens so we didn't know how things would
recover
we increase our vacancy management
Factor based on the previous year's
activity in relation to recruitment the
challenge for backfilling vacant posts
when someone leaves has already been
well rehearsed
overall our head count has increased but
what we are facing in some cases is
longer periods whilst posts are unfilled
due to difficulty in attracting suitable
candidates
the result is some teams feeling very
stretched and under pressure
as they were longer hours to cover the
work that's left behind when someone
leaves
we know this is something our senior
management team are addressing as a
matter of urgency
we are proposing to allocate the 1.208
million surplus across four Reserve
headings
to put 500 000 to a new inflationary
pressure Reserve
154 000 to the waste Reserve 361 000 to
planning legal reserve and the balance
which is 193 000 to our growth and
efficiency Reserve
we'll then have over 24 million in
general fund earmark reserves excluding
sell as at the end of the year and
that's set out in paragraph 5.8 in the
papers
so we're recommending creating this new
inflatory pressure Reserve as in second
to 22 23 budget we do have stretching
income targets we've absorbed inflation
assumed inflation in all our
departmental budgets
as inflation pressures continue to grow
though we're likely to see some budgets
they were spent this year that we may
need to call on this Reserve to manage
that scenario
the finance team are working on the
impact to the financial position on our
budget from pay inflation and fuel
increases energy costs and interest rate
impacts
all I can say is thank goodness we do
have such a healthy and growing level
reserves to our due to our past prudent
financial management and our various
established external income streams
turning now to capital expenditure the
incurred expenditure of 13.309 million
in the year we've got contractual
commitments to the year end for a
further 377 000 and in addition we are
requesting to carry forward 20 million
0.156 with a breakout of that set out in
paragraph 515.
now the biggest component by far is our
exciting and ambitious Gateway 14
projects at Stone Market which is 12.75
million of that capital
it might appear at First Sight from the
use of the term adverse variance that
you'll see in paragraphs 5 12 and 5 13.
that we've actually overspent on some of
our capital projects in the year but
that's an accounting Quirk the
additional spend on capital projects
comes from external grants and the use
of still and sector 106 money and not
from our own resources and to me that's
a positive thing building valuable
infrastructure but using external
funding sources
and I was always before finishing this
brief outturn introduction I want to pay
tribute to all the hard work undertaken
by our finance team in the production of
this report and all its underlying
numbers and Analysis
and in closing I'd now like to move the
full recommendations set out in
paragraph three
that includes noting that 1.208 million
Revenue Surplus
noting the various Revenue carry forward
requests totaling 399 000 that have been
approved by our section 151 officer
approving the four transfers to reserves
as I've already mentioned and lastly
approving the various Capital Carry
forward requests
I'll be happy to answer any questions
members may have on this very detailed
report
but first I'd ask for a second of these
recommendations thank you chair
thank you councilor Whitehead do we have
a second to please councilor Gould
thank you very much chair and thank you
councilor Whitehead
for his report and also as always for
his very helpful and comprehensive
introduction to to the report and and to
thank John I know as his cabinet
colleagues are are very appreciative of
the hard work John does in terms of uh
in respect of the in the budget not
least in these in these in these
difficult times
I'm very pleased to Second the report
and the recommendations in it
I'd like as as Council White had
mentioned I think the some of the
context of the narrative behind this is
is important not least the decision we
took in terms of the council tax
for the current year I think that was a
important decision that we that we took
there and I know it will be appreciated
uh by our by our residents
um I'd also um you know these are very
difficult times we when we set the
budget we had no notion at all about the
levels of inflation or the level of
unpredictability that is around in in in
in managing that budget and I think the
approach that we're taking not least in
relation to inflation uh is is is very
sensible uh which in we have made a
provision of proposing to make that
provision in reserves of half a million
to deal with those uncertainties but in
the first place uh know that we can rely
on service managers to do the very best
that they can to absorb those pressures
uh within within their their services
and finally I just like to take the
opportunity to congratulate Melissa on
her appointment particularly at a time
of um virtually unprecedented inflation
and we're in for an exciting ride but uh
thank you to Melissa and her team for
the work that they do thank you very
much chair
thank you Council Gordon and yes of
course I'd like to Echo again the
congratulations to Melissa Evans on her
appointment as director of corporate
resources I'll now go to questions but
before I do just a sort of polite
reminder to members that as we do have
quite an extensive agenda today if
questions could be as succinct as
possible that would greatly appreciated
so first are there any questions from
cabinet members
are there any questions from other
members present Council field
thank you
it's always tempting to nitpick the
little numbers that we're trying to
avoid that but I have to point out that
uh solar panel income is down 72k on
141k budget due to light being low in
August it stretches the imagination
that's hardly the most important thing
in the world to discuss the issue I just
wanted to ask councilor what I did
really was
um you know you know I hear all the
reasons the excuses whatever you want to
call them and obviously a number of them
are well known and pretty valid but
we always seem to understand our budget
and that that means there's Services
which we could provide to local people
particularly perhaps those in need which
we're not delivering we can't save a
million pounds and deliver what we
intended to originally perhaps
and the my perception to an extent
there's a number of that amount of that
is due to sort of pessimistic
forecasting we forecast more spend and
less income than we we expect and we do
this repetitively
we seem to have done the same this year
his counselor wanted really happy with
that position as I bear in mind that we
have a million pounds it is great to use
it is sensible to put into an inflation
Reserve but it is a million pounds we're
not delivering to the people of
Mid-South
thank you thank you councilor field
Council Whitehead
I'll try and be succinct I'd like to
shine that light on the solar panels but
I'll pass on that one
um the um in terms of the underspend and
the pessimistic forecast I mean I think
we can't necessarily rely on hindsight
um back in the winter of 2020 I think
the world did feel very different and so
I think it was correct that we
through
in terms of forecasting with a I'd say
prudent I rather pessimistic eye but um
the wrong trial out promised everything
but as far as I'm aware I I'm not aware
members can correct me for like but in
terms of where we where we haven't
delivered that I think the the staff
have gone the extra mile where there
have been vacancies in covering for
absentees and
um the uh
you know additional to the basic
statutory services and the services that
we strategically want to deliver we've
also spent a great deal of time and
effort in terms of looking for you know
additional areas that we can spend if I
really put aside on the amount of work
that's gone into that which I think
there's 50 different projects within
that so you know I refute the view that
we basically haven't delivered
um but in terms of um
how you know in terms of service
delivery I'm really happy to see if the
chief education wants to put his own
point of view in terms of how to pay
service on that
and so I had no I wasn't particularly
going to I think you hit the nail on the
head in terms of we're continuing to
deliver Services as effectively as we
possibly can we also continue to do
those do that in a way that is most
efficient as possible because just
because I've got the money doesn't mean
we should spend the money of course
because it's always public funds
um but yes mid suffolks in it in their
luxury of being in a strong financial
position that's a good thing
um I'd also say whilst it may look
overly pessimistic if you look backwards
in terms of economic forecasts I think
this year his daughter's there's nothing
else that perhaps we haven't been
pessimistic enough in terms of the
current state of the economy so we can
all we can do at any given point in time
and particularly when budgets are set in
February is do our best forecasts same
as the bank of England same as the
government and then deliver against
those and thank you for Council
Whitehead's words I think we are
delivering effectively but we always
want to do more
lovely thank you very much are there any
other questions yes councilor Mellon
um yes thank you
um
councilor Whitehead has just referred to
the I think it was four million we
initially set aside which rose to 5.1
million and I'm sure remember last
this time last year I asked him how much
of that had been spent and it wasn't a
great deal
um how much of that five point William
5.1 million has now been spent
that's what I had okay
um so I think your question last time
was how much you thought we would be
spending by the end of the financial
year which just 31st of March so from
that point of view I'd refer you back to
that answer which I think was somewhere
in the sort of quarter million Mark
which obviously is a small amount
um we're now three more months into it
and uh
you know the finance team and myself
have also been concentrating on the out
term for now we'll be bringing the first
quarter
um projection forward I think in August
or September September 5th of September
but we obviously have that an early
sight of that and of course the first
quarter projection we'll look at the uh
anticipated out term for next year so I
don't have any figures to hand just now
for the spend from April through to June
but um as we speak they're being worked
on thank you
thank you very much councilor Whitehead
uh are there any other questions
no in that case I will open up the item
for debates are there any members of the
cabinet who would like to debate this
item
so in that case I think we'll move
straight onto the boat can I have a show
of hands for all those in favor please
that's unanimous
thank you very much
uh moving now on to item nine paper MCA
slash 22-7 the housing revenue account
draft Financial outturn
2021-22 uh I now invite the cabinet
member for finance to introduce the
report councilor Whitehead
thank you Jim
so I'm now pleased to introduce a second
out term report in today's packed agenda
MCA 22 7.
which covers the outcome of 2122 of our
ring fenced housing revenue account the
HRA
I'll try and keep this brief the HRA
covers Council housing stock over 3 300
dwellings along with Associated garages
and land Holdings and in the year under
review we had budgeted linear surplus of
102 000 and the outturn is in fact a
service of 113 000. it's a little
difference overall
our actual total income unsurprisingly
comes in well within one percent of that
budgeted so I concentrate on the
expenditure side
the analysis in the table in paragraph
6.5 shows several significant variances
within our various expenditure headings
despite the overall net difference being
very minor
Building Services had a net adverse
variance of 407 000. and there's 13
bullet points set out as an explanation
for that in paragraph 6.8 so it's given
that details are there I won't repeat
them verbally but the main issue to note
is the use of subcontractors to assist
in completing the backlog of void and
responsive repairs and maintenance built
up during the code with 19 period
our depreciation charge was 578 000
above budget as a result of the increase
in evaluation of our housing stock but
this is a book entry with no cash flow
implications and there's a contra entry
I.E opposite and equal as a saving in
the revenue and contribution to Capital
on the plus side we have Savings of
Interest payable of three twenty five
thousand
and a re-evaluation of our bet debt
provision has released 68 000.
the report also looks at a capital
program and the details of that are set
out in the table within paragraph 616
and then appendix a
we're talking pretty substantial numbers
here as usual
we've spent 13.907 million on this
Capital program during the year
we've contracted for a further
1.9009
1.9099 million
and our rust cabinet today is the
request to carry forward a further 24
million six hundred thirty one thousand
about two years of spending at our
current spend rate as set out in
paragraph 619
it is vital that these carry forward
requests are approved to enable us to
complete the important ambitious housing
schemes in progress
now before I propose recommendations I'd
just like to add my own thanks and
tributes to our director for housing
Gavin Fisk before he leaves us tomorrow
to take up his new rail across the road
I've really enjoyed working with Gavin
on many HRA matters over several years
our HRA has faced many challenges which
he has tackled and addressed with both
sincerity and a clear passion and I feel
his dedication and commitment should
serve as a role model to us all
and as always I'd like to thank the
family Steve for all their hard work in
pulling the outturn numbers in this
report together
so chairman without further Ado I'd like
to move the three recommendations set
out in section three and we myself
Lavinia Gavin and finance team I hear
transfer any questions that members may
have
but first I'll invite the cabinet member
for housing to Second as recommendations
thank you thank you councilor Whitehead
councilor housing thanks I'm happy to
second that thanks
thank you very much are there any
questions from cabinet members
are there any questions from other
members present
castlefield
just the issue of the carry forward
request 24 million does sound like a
very large number is is this something
always intended or
I have to confess I've read every
paragraph for this report so so they
could do enlighten me a little as why as
why is that actually as you you were
suggesting a couple of years of spend
since
a very large number
thank you Council field councilor
Whitehead
nothing
there are a number of um fairly
significant schemes in terms of the new
bill program I mean after that 24
million 22.734 is which is what 90 I
would guess of that spend is on this new
build program and Acquisitions so
um the you know Acquisitions come
through various things like the section
106 and there's planning things go
through uh so it's not a quick it's not
a quick thing at all to sort of deliver
those and we see we've spent 12 million
during the year so you say 24 million is
two years worth but um I think it just
sort of highlights the the breadth and
scope and ambition of our housing
program
um but if you have been wants to add
anything beyond that I'm happy to to
tell you that or or Emily
thank you so um we have around about 350
homes in our new homes in our pipeline
over the next five years
um so that uh you know that will deliver
um those new homes using the 24 million
carry forward we have had some delays in
terms of the delivery of some of the
schemes over the last couple of years
caused through
um well a number of different issues
like covid difficulties with Supply
labor
Etc so some of our schemes are a little
bit delayed but we do have a
considerable number in the pipeline
currently and delivered around about 140
homes and
over the last over the previous sort of
three or four years so it's quite a
significant carry forward but that does
equal the sort of significant
acquisition and new build program that
we we have in place currently
thank you very much are there any other
questions for councilor Whitehead or
Council Academy
in that case I'll open this item Up For
Debate are there any members of the
cabinet who would like to debate this
item
nope in that case I suggest we move as
we've got a proposal and a secondary uh
suggest we move on to the vote of the
three recommendations in the uh in our
report so can I have a show of hands all
those in favor please
that is unanimous
thank you very much uh moving down to
item 10 paper MCA slash 22-8 the
approval of the housing revenue account
business plan and I'd now I'd like to
invite the cabinet member for housing to
introduce the report councilor hadigan
I'm pleased to introduce report MC 22-7
typically a housing revenue account
business plan sets out the priorities
plans and actions for Council housing
over the next 30 Years
our HRA business plans last revised in
May 2017 therefore it is pertinent that
after five years a fundamental review of
the plan and its priorities took place
the purpose of such plans is to show
that we can maintain our existing
housing assets and deliver a quality
customer focused Service as well as
improve homes in the neighborhoods while
supporting and endeavoring to achieve
the visions of the organization's key
strategies
an effective HRA business plan has
become ever more crucial since central
government announced the reform of the
rules governing local Authority Housing
Finance and the introduction of the
self-financing system a decade ago
members may recall that last year they
were both invited and consulted on what
they saw with their merging priorities
When developing the HRA business plan
this included surveys and a focus group
whilst in January this year a paper was
presented to the full Council on the
progress being made to develop the plan
and what the guiding principles of the
plan would be
then maybe held an old member briefing
on the HRA business plan for which we
produced a frequently Asked question
answer sheet in response to members
questions today you have the report and
final version of the plan in front of
you which provides understanding of the
HRA business plan and its aims and
objectives ever ahead of it being
approved here today in cabinets
I'm pleased to promote the key aims of
the plan which include increasing the
stock of social housing owned by the HOA
through an ambitious development program
including on average up to 65 new homes
each year over the next six years
each year for the next six years
developing new homes that are built to
the highest standard contributing to the
council's effort to ensure carbon
neutrality including an important
affordable housing strategy a new build
design guide and Technical specification
improve their quality of existing homes
and communal areas and reduce the carbon
footprint of existing Castle homes for
investment in assets community-led
regeneration working with communities
and individuals
including the investment of more than 14
million pounds to ensure every home
meets the epc3 by 2013 ensuring that our
homes and the management of them
maintain and improve well-being outcomes
for individuals families and communities
alongside other Council services and
partners
making sure that HRA business plans
continue to continue to remain
financially viable and sustainable it is
vital that HRA has a balanced financial
plan that repays its debt within a
reasonable period of time therefore we
currently live we can currently afford
to build 65 new homes for each of the
next six years further itinerations of
the HRA business plan and review reviews
in subsequent years will determine the
number that the cow afford to build in
year seven eight and onwards the exact
number that we can build in year seven
and onwards will be dependent on
continuously renewing the HRA reviewing
the HRA finances nearer the time on an
annual basis and accounting for changes
that cannot be predicted today EG
further Rises and Falls of an income or
expansion
the plan is focused on seven main
priorities which are tackling adapting
to climate change developing new Council
housing investing in our current homes
involving our tenants in the running of
the housing service improving the
service that we provide to our tenants
improving the neighborhoods that we
manage and implementing the digital
transformation
inevitably there'll be challenges ahead
including maximizing our income which by
2025-26 will be as much as 20 million
pounds per year as well as being
efficient and delivering value for money
in our expenditure which by 2025-26 will
have included include having invested
more than 17 million pounds on repairs
to council homes more than 23 million
pounds on Capital Improvement
improvements to existing homes and more
than 62 million pounds on investing in
new homes as well as 33 million pounds
of additional borrowing
so I'd like to promote proposed
recommendations 3.1 and 3.2 and ask for
a second but before that I'd also like
to thank Gavin for his um for his hard
work over the last 16 years to
mid-suffolk and to say that I appreciate
all this work and wish him well in the
future thank you
thank you Council had him do we have a
second though please Council platman
thank you very much are there any
questions from cabinet members on this
are there any questions from other
members present
Council field
thank you couple of them I
have one which so similar to ones that
I've asked before about the rent
increase reflects CPI plus one percent
I wondered what the portfolio holders
view is on the
impact that we'll have on residents
bearing in mind that certainly RPI and
probably CPI are going to be around 10
or more percent
pretty dramatic increase compared with
increases in income
the second thing
or a certainly different charities and
notice we're talking about building new
homes and acquiring new homes I didn't
see any estimates of the different costs
of those two approaches I mean
presumably one of them
involves paying substantial amounts to
Developers
for conventional sites the other money
involved us building on a rural
exception sites for instance so I
wondered if there was any core
difference in the cost of those two
approaches to X
from my stretch to number three
6.3 a series of financial scenarios also
developed which included and there's I
I noticed any statement of what the
decisions were on those scenarios thank
you
Council field Council had again
thank you the first question that we did
answer at full Council as you remember
and I appreciate it's something that we
need to keep an eye on I say CPI who
knows what will happen in the future and
obviously it is something that we're all
concerned with but um but we did um we
come to that for Council that the second
one
um I'm going to ask probably Emily to
answer that if not Gavin or Hazel
um
and um and the third one which on page
was that you said that that was it 6.2
are you just saying it doesn't make
sense or um
perhaps um
Council feel perhaps I can bring in
offices just walk out so they're having
him is finding the relevant bid can I
invite you the director of housing
please thank you
um I'll attempt to answer the the first
and the third question and then perhaps
ask Emily to help with uh question two
um just in relation to uh what may
happen with any rent increase next year
obviously the government sets out
through a rent standard its expectations
to protect uh rents from increase and
exponentially so the CPI plus one
percent is actually set out uh in uh in
directions to us and all landlords we
would expect the government that they
would need to be making a decision by
September if they were to vary uh those
uh those current uh planned changes from
from April
um there is a lot of talk in the sector
as to what may happen with rent
increases uh next year there's obviously
uh implications there's advantages and
disadvantages of of all options and it
could well be that the sector is uh
to make some decisions in terms of just
being practical just being Mindful and
considerate of the the current economic
circumstances so whilst uh CPI for
example was 10 10
maybe uh landlords will choose to to to
implement a figure lower than that and
then play catch-up over over future
years um if if possible obviously there
is an impact
um uh whilst we want to protect tenants
and residents from uh significant rent
increases it doesn't stop the
inflationary pressures that the HRA
faces in terms of material costs and the
alike so clearly that the service needs
to be fit for purpose and and affordable
and they will be decisions that will
need to be taken over the forthcoming
months as part of the budget setting
process and as part of any changes that
the government implements or choose it
to or not
um in relation to the last question
Council of field had and this was
discussed at full Council and I made an
apology then and I apologize again now
just to be clear 6.3
um there were initially seven uh
scenario scoped and were developed
alongside our uh HRA business plan
consultant uh who offices advice and
then after we developed those seven
scenarios we then started to boil those
down uh distill those to the two
scenarios that you have in front of you
today in in the report
thank you very much uh yes if I can
invite the director of assets and
Investments to comment thank you
thank
you
thank
you
um so the value and cost
basis so whether that's properties that
we're building ourselves directly or
whether they're
um homes that we're acquiring through
106 and Provisions and and so because of
this we apply a similar approach across
all of the schemes so that we can
determine whether we're achieving best
value effectively for
to pull the council so we use um Net
Present Value and when assetting schemes
so we need a positive Net Present Value
in order to proceed with the scheme so
whether that's a new build scheme or
whether it's a
an acquisition That's the basis we look
at and that's looking at really the
value that those new units deliver to
the
um HRA over a longer period of time so
it looks not just at the build cost but
also at the um
lifetime costs effectively of those
units as well so that's how we assess in
terms of both new build and Acquisitions
and that's probably a more consistent
approach rather than looking at it on a
unit by unit because location
the cost of development because of any
particular site but also from a value
perspective as well
thank you very much are there any other
questions from Members councilor Mellon
yes thank you chair
um it's a question on the design guide
which is part of the report
and it's really a question on what I
think is
Lowered Expectations
um in the ex in the section on resources
and lifespan there are a number of
things we say that we will do
uh in terms of new homes that we're
building in particular meeting the part
L 2022 building regulations which I
understand we have to do anyway
and then we have a number of aspirations
such as meeting zero carbon Targets in
all future homes
and reaching the passive house standard
or something similar can I ask why this
is only an aspiration rather than
something we will definitely commit to
I think we did um also cover this your
colleague Andrew Stringer answer the
same question at full Council and I can
ask Emily to repeat her answer if you
like
the director for assets and Investments
please thank you thank you so um within
the design guide we have some
commitments that we we will make and
some aspirational commitments and it
really reflects the fact that the
schemes that we're delivering are quite
different so in some circumstances it
will be possible to achieve all of our
aspirational criteria whereas in other
circumstances it won't be possible so
for instance we're dealing with in some
cases of sites that might be one or two
units compared to sites of 40 or 50
units it's very different things that
you can provide across those two
differing opportunities so it's really
to ensure that we've got some
flexibility
while still aspiring to delivering the
um the most sustainable homes that we
can for any of the developments that we
deliver but reflecting the fact that the
nature of these schemes could be very
different and so we need that additional
flexibility we can continue to try and
Achieve
um as many of the aspirational uh
areas as we can for each and every one
of our new build developments
thank you very much if there are no
further questions and I suggest we move
on to the debate are there any members
of the cabinet who would like to debate
this item
cancel the Whitehead
maybe not so much debate but I didn't
like to say that I really do welcome
this report I mean something like the
HRA which is Standalone and well ring
fencing has stand on its own two feet uh
it's vital that we do have a 30-year
business plan I was a bit frustrated to
some extent that that this hadn't come
you know when we did the last budget we
didn't have this to hang but
at the same time it is important we do
we do something quickly or we do
something correctly and properly and I
think the reality is that this needed a
lot of hard work there's a lot of detail
in there but now it's there to be
adopted and it's you know it's there for
the future
um I think we can't underestimate the
challenges we Face going forward such
thing as an inflation and the cost of
getting to a EPC C Level but at least
now we've got the backbone and and the
plan
and guidance to achieve that
keep
thank you very much councilor Whitehead
uh if there are no other members wishing
to take part in the debate then we'll
move to the vote which are is on
recommendations 3.1 and 3.2 in our
report uh can I have a show of hands for
all those in favor please
that is unanimous
moving on now to item 11 paper MCA slash
22-9 the empty homes policy 2022 I'll
now invite the cabinet member for
housing to introduce the report
councilor haddington
thank you very much
homes ever
teeth and members of historically asked
them all to be done to help resolve the
blight they cause
the adoption of the policy will help us
to provide more homes supporting our aim
and to maximize the use of the private
sector to help address the need for
local housing refurbishing long-term
empty homes particularly those that have
been left for long periods of time is a
big Financial commitment and we know
that some are struggling to even get
started
residents are encouraged to take
advantage of the empty home renovation
loan which I'm sure make a real
difference in helping empty homeowners
take the first step in restoring these
homes
policy before you today will support
officers and their work to achieve these
aims and bring long-term empty
properties back into use
with the dedicated resources for both
baber and mid-suffolk it's important
that we have approved policy for
officers to work to
substantial work has taken place to
draft this policy and was scrutinized
for over two hours it's overview and
scrutiny unanimous
unanimously approve the policy
mid-suffolk members are recall in
November last year cabinet approved
funding for empty homes work as part of
the Strategic priority Reserves
successful recruitment has taken place
and we have a dedicated member of staff
from mid-suffolk for the next two years
approval of this policy will support the
delivery of this strategic priority
thank
thank you council haddington could I ask
for a second uh please councilor
Brewster thank you very much
thank you um
chair
um yes I'm very happy to Second do this
so I think it will improve our district
with you know houses which are falling
into disrepair and so on and we have to
stop that in some way so and this looks
to be the very West best way of doing it
thank you very much Council Barista are
there any members of the cabinet who
would like to ask questions
are there any questions from other
members present
in that case we will open the item of
the debate are there any members of the
cabinet who would like to debate this
item
no in that case I suggest we move to a
vote on the recommendations in our
report that's recommendations 3.1 and
3.2 could I have a vote a show of hands
for all those in favor please
thank you that is unanimous
moving now on to item number 12 uh paper
MCA slash 22 10 the rent and service
charge policy uh I'll now invite to the
cabinet member for housing to introduce
the report Castle
thank you
um
I'm here to present you the rent and
service charge policy it's SRC
contributes to our housing Vision
supporting our strategic aim to Be an
Effective social landlord for delivering
and delivering quality service
policy sets out how the council will set
rents for Council housing in accordance
with the just I can't speak legit
legislative
legislative legislative that's it and
regulatory requirements aside from
consolidating our current working
practices and rent setting this policy
proposes to modernize the future
application of service charging to
tenants
policy paves the way for d for the Deep
pooling service charges
the Deep pooling service charges that is
to charge tenants for the services they
receive in addition to their rent rather
than the cost of them being subsidized
by the general rent pool this practice
is widely adopted in the social housing
sector will enable us to improve service
provision and demonstrate to our tenants
our commitment to transparency and
fairness which is essential As We rise
to meet the changing demands of central
government and the regulator regulatory
for social housing
government policy of Permitting rent
increases up to CPI plus one percent is
only guaranteed until 2025. the
potential for a less favorable deal in
the future presents a significant risk
to the council's medium and long-term
Financial plans
deep pooling service charges will
mitigate some of the impact a change in
government policy might have enabling
the council to deliver the objectives of
the HRA business plans including
improving the Energy Efficiency of homes
and being proactive to meet the needs of
tenants in housing management and
raising standards
members all night that we will leave we
leave the door open to rent flexibility
as being an alternative means to
generating additional income which can
be a decision made in the future perhaps
at a time when the cost of living crisis
have subsided
both portfolio holders and officers have
been working hard to develop this
strategy and the principles were shared
more widely last year through our all
member housing briefings we need to be
clear that it's imperative that we have
such a policy in place to ensure we are
compliant with the regulatory standards
for which we know there is greater
scrutiny of the management of council
housing than ever before thank you
thank you councilor hardingham do I have
a second uh please councilor flatlin
thank you very much uh do members of the
cabinet wish to ask any questions on
this item
are there any questions from other
members present
in that case I'll open the item up to
debate with any uh Cabinet member like
to debate this uh item in the agenda
in that case I suggest we move to the
votes which is our recommendation uh 3.1
in our report could I have a show of
hands for all those in favor please
that is unanimous thank you very much
moving now on to item number 14 paper
MCA slash uh 22 11 gateway to Home
Choice allocations policy review and
amendments I'll now invite the cabinet
member for housing to introduce the
report uh councilor Hadley
babe and mid Suffolk is a part of a very
success
our affordable housing stock for
councils and our Housing Association
partners
the allocations policy ensures a fair
and consistent approach across Suffolk
and North Essex it is vital that the
policy is kept up to date in response to
changing legislation legislation
legislation
that
think you all know what I'm saying the
main changes to the policy are in
response to the new legislation and
guidance for domestic abuse and Care
leavers at the same time we've taken the
opportunity to update grammar and other
minor word changes
Moulton Council and ourselves the last
three councils in the Consortium left to
approve these changes
the changes are earnest response to
legislation changes and not a whole
scale review of the allocations policy
members may have views and thoughts on
other changes they would like to see in
the policy such changes need to be fed
into fed into me and officers so they
can be considered as wide as part of any
wider review of the allocations policy
remembering that we are part of a
Consortium
if the changes are not approved this
legal challenge the allocations policy
and jeopardize other councils in the
Consortium equally the changes proposed
are the benefit to the victims of
domestic abuse and Care leavers to
vulnerable groups in society
the successful Consortium of councils
there's been an operation since 2009
working as a Consortium we've
substantially reduced our operating
costs and benefit from wider knowledge
and expertise
it's no mean feat for the Consortium of
seven councils to work together
successfully the management of housing
applications and the allocation
s and the allocation of various scarce
but high demand product is a massive
challenge this shared allocation policy
means we we stay up to date with
legislation and reduce the risks of
legal challenge that so many other
authorities experience
this report has two recommendations
approval of the proposed amendments and
delegated authority for future minor
changes other councils in the Consortium
already have delegations established and
this facilitates quick care responsive
small changes and does not delay other
councils from Implement
implementation the
delegation would bring us into line with
other health other how other councils
operate I apologize to my terrible
speaking
thank you very much councilor hattingham
uh do we have a second death please
Council flatman thank you very much
are there any questions from cabinet
members for this item
are there any questions from other
members present
castlefield
yes
difficult one in one
certainly
I've received complaints from residents
that imply that
this
process this policy
adversely impacts young people who are
seeking to basically live I guess in The
Villages or at least in the county in
which they were born
so it's
tends to attract people from northern it
Essex who are basically immigrating out
to suffer to a nice place to retire
I did myself some perhaps shouldn't
complain but but just your view on that
is that a fair
assessment or do young people from
Suffolk migrate down the game Council of
housing in in Essex to support jobs in
that area
shoes
um
I I don't sit that way and I wouldn't
say that that is how it is um presented
and unfortunately Justin isn't here who
um who wrote this report but um but
Gavin isn't so I'm sure he can give you
on his views on the matter
thank you if I can invite the director
of housing to comment please
sure um I may stop I may ask uh
us over to to Karen Carter who's sitting
uh to the side of me Karen works with in
the allocations and assessments team and
works as a as a senior officer within
that team
um it in just in terms of if I start and
then uh Karen can can chip in there is a
quite a fundamental process and a review
that goes on within the CBL sub-region
to monitor Trends and data and I think
we've recently shared uh the the last
year's report in that regard if we see
significant inward migration then we can
flex and change the policy to support
that sort of balancing out or
counteracting itself
um invariably people will move for all
sorts of reasons and I don't think it's
just focused on a certain demo
demographic I think what we're seeing
through choice-based lettings and the
opportunities at the Gateway Home Choice
sub-regional have given us over the last
uh 10 years or more is actually the
ability for residents to migrate in and
out subject to
Lifestyles economic circumstances
employment family the list goes on and
actually what we're seeing overall is a
reduction in our overall numbers on
waiting lists which can only be a good
thing and an assumption that actually
we're making best use of of the stock
that we have available a bit if I asked
Karen to come in and perhaps just
comment on the specifics
yes we can advertise our properties that
are restricted to our own districts so
applicants would have to have a
connection so either working or family
members in our district and that depends
on the migration of people going in and
out of the districts and this is done on
a quarterly basis by the gateway to Home
Choice coordinator and runs the
statistics to work out how many people
we've housed from out of the the
districts and how many are going in and
whether that restriction stays in place
so that's how that works
thank you very much are there any other
questions from members
in that case I'll open the item for
debate are there any members of the
cabinet who would like to debate this
item
Council Whitehead
just reading in terms of the options it
says that the these Chase recommended
recommended there are no other options
to consider because we need to comply
with the statutory framework I think
probably
has hadn't had anyone would say herself
as a council we cannot legislate for how
the legislative legislation was being
brought in by the legislation
I'm feeling very similar to that
thank you very much Council Whitehead
um very eloquently put
um in that case can I suggest we move uh
to the vote uh which is on
recommendations 3.1 and 3.2
uh so in that case gonna have a share of
hands for all those in favor please
thank you very much
moving now on to item number 15 paper
MCA slash 22-12 uh the quarter four
performance report and in councilor
Morley's absence I will offer an
overview of performance highlights for
quarter four of 2021-22 for each of the
six strategic priorities these are all
examples of how we are enhancing the
lives of our residents and our
communities across our district
in economy we completed the master
planning work and options appraisal for
The Stone Market health education and
Leisure facility we published the
economic recovery strategy and we agreed
a knowledge transfer partnership with
the University of Essex to be jointly
funded
in the environment the main construction
work on the solar carports at
mid-suffolk Leisure Center in stowmarket
was completed in quarter four at the
tree canopy report and tree inventory
report were finalized and we agreed the
council's first climate change in
biodiversity annual report
for customers we delivered an automated
telephone survey and used the results to
plan improvements we worked with tenants
to agree how to improve digital
inclusion and identified wards where
more support is needed on digital skills
and we are continuing to work with
citizens advice to explore options to
locate digital hubs trials and are
linking this with work around the cost
of living crisis
in communities we survey young people in
high schools in mid-suffolk and baber
the questions of which focused on Health
Community safety and local democracy
a domestic abuse Champions group has
been established to develop an action
plan across mid-suffolk and its
communities and half a million pounds of
funding has now been spent to support
local community groups and their
projects
in well-being we provided a range of
activities for children and their
families over February half term we've
worked with Everyone Active to develop
Health Pathways offering those referred
by GPS and discharged from hospital with
long-term conditions a package of
Rehabilitation at Stone Market Leisure
Center
finally in housing we granted 46 housing
specific planning applications to
deliver
517 homes and started the tenant
engagement strategy and improved our
choice-based lettings processes to speed
up new tenants getting housed
now this item is for noting only so we
will be voting on it but if there are
questions from members of the cabinet or
other members present that I'm happy to
take those now are there any questions
from members of the cabinet
are any questions for from members
present
castlefield
yes just uh noting the re 14 of
recycling collected was identified as
contaminated or too small to process
um
that does seemed quite a substantial
number and I I know you know we've had
other discussions recently about uh
government inspired changes that were
going to introduce which aim at uh
segregating waste to a greater extent
this sort of implies a lack of
well does this imply a lack of buy-in
from certain residents
or is it just confusion in the in the
communication we have with them
and
presumably the under 45 millimeters
means that just stuff that drops through
the bottom of the um
sorting cylinder whatever it's called
I've lost the words
um
it's discarded but of no particular
issue doesn't contaminate other waste in
any way so it's really the question is
what drives that 14 is it lack of buy-in
or poor communication with people who
would otherwise make a better attempt
and thank you very much uh Council field
I think in councilor Fleming's absence
I'll invite the director of environment
and Commercial Partnerships to answer
that question and
thank you chair thank you for the
question counselor field so you're right
14 is particularly high in terms of
contamination
um that is a similar
um percentage across Suffolk actually so
there is a a wider issue across Suffolk
not just for mid-suffolk for us it's
something that Suffolk waste partnership
have been working on for some time each
year we commission and some work to have
a look at what our contamination rates
are so we can keep an eye on them
predominantly as it says in there that
people are bagging waste particularly
recycling you mentioned the mixed
recycling facility there and things
can't get sorted if they're bagged in
recycling so that's one issue so that
automatically gets taken out of the
process and then things like dirty items
in the recycling all add to it you
absolutely right anything under 45 drops
through the machine and it's therefore
it's seen as a contamination as well
I think it's a combination of what
you've said so it is a combination of
people misunderstanding and not for any
fault of their own just being confused
about the process and then there is a
choice around negligence in terms of
recycling as well and it's something
that Suffolk waste partnership continue
to Monitor and put out campaigns on
there's more work going on this year in
terms of people trying to understand
what they should be doing how they
should be dealing with their recycling
in terms of what's going to happen with
resource and waste strategy and that has
to have a whole new communication
strategy to go with it so
um as tough as it is for some people now
to understand what they need to do
around recycling it will all change so
um yes lots of work going on in terms of
what we will need to be done for
education for that new so
thank you very much uh councilor field
thank you for your discretion just to
comment on that
I mean the thing that always concerns me
is that you do run into people for
instance who will say I'm not putting
let's call it dirty nappies but
smelly
stuff
in my bin and having it sitting there
for two weeks it gets appalling so what
I do is I'll stick it in the bin that
goes every week so one week it goes in
the back bin and next week it goes in
the the green bin
which does seem like a you know a major
communication problem and of course I'm
sure as we all have problems with
counselors you never know whether that's
one person in a thousand or one person
in a hundred or you know one in
you know um it's difficult to judge the
impact of those sort of comments whether
they're real and how many people are in
effect but
would just try and emphasize again the
communication does really need to get to
to the small number of people who don't
play the game properly and
problems and of course we all know as
well sometimes it's not exactly easy to
understand what you should be doing with
certain items like the 45 millimeter
ones thank you thank you Council if I
could invite the director of
environments comment please thank you
thank you I don't normally like to
challenge counselors in the chamber but
I'd say that we don't have weekly
collections so we only have alternate
week collections recycling one week and
residual the next so there is an as
either week
um you would be waiting for the bin to
go and for another week so that that
would be the situation however what I
would say is anybody that's struggling
with their waste we've got options for
people that are bespoke to their
household so if they are struggling with
dirty nappies that kind of thing they
can talk to our team and there are
things we can do around additional
collections for them so whether it's a
bin collection or additional bags that
we can give them to collect them so what
I'd say is anybody that's having any
kind of issues with their waste just to
get in touch with our our waste team and
they'll sort out a solution for them
Council field if it's a quick follow-up
question
this question it will be good to let
people know that that service is
available clearly and what I meant was
if I've got a dirty nappy to dispose of
this week it goes in my black bin okay
no problem next week it goes in the
green bin because that's going to go
this week and that is a problem thank
you thank you and I think in councilor
Fleming's absence I think customer
writing is saying this is your last
mid-suffolk cabinet meeting in that case
thank you again for all of your hard
work and your time with us and we wish
you all the very best in the future
key are there any questions on the rest
of this report
so this report was for noting only so
we'll now move on to the next gender
item item 16 paper MCA slash 22 13 the
UK shared Prosperity fund and I'll now
invite the cabinet member for
communities to introduce the reports
Council Flatland
2022 the government launched a 2.6
billion UK shared Prosperity fund
at UK SPF just thought the leveling up
the gender the allocation from this
National Fund for mid-suffolk was one
million
1061 918 pounds the aim and purpose of
this funding is to provide a successor
to the UE structural funds ESF and to
build pride in place and increase life
chances across the UK whilst the scheme
has been promoted by government as a
replacement for EU funds there are
significantly fewer funds available than
had been available via EU schemes so any
project allocation will need to be
carefully managed the fund will Empower
each place to identify and build on
their own strengths and needs at a local
level focused on building pride in place
underneath the overarching aim of the
building pride in place and increasing
life chances there are three UK SPF
investment priorities
communities in place supporting local
business and people and skills
authorities are encouraged to identify
activities that will support these
objectives in their area including any
innovations that are best delivered at a
larger scale in collaboration with other
authorities or wider partners
this would be informed by engagement
with local stakeholders and partners
Council must outline their proposals in
an investment plan which must be
submitted to government by the 1st of
August
investment plan development
in order to facilitate the development
of the plans we have formed internal
officer groups and worked across Suffolk
authorities to discuss key priorities
and funding
potential projects have been identified
from a range of adopted Council
strategic strategies including the
communities and well-being strategies
and the Econo economic recovery plan to
ensure that the funding helps to deliver
against recognized need within the
district and meet agreed outcomes
these projects have been grouped into
wider thematic areas provide to provide
for for future flexibility and are
ongoing a wide stakeholder engagement
process to make sure they are supported
locally
they include schemes to support youth
social prescribing social Enterprise
small businesses and Community
supermarkets to name just a few
finally as part of the wider Suffolk
discussions spsl has agreed to top slice
funds from each authority to provide
suffolk-wide schemes around business
support and growth and skills as these
areas are impacted by a loss of EU
funding we are Consulting on the
proposals at a local and Suffolk wide
level and will ensure feedback from the
engagement is fed into the final plans I
am asking I am I am therefore asking
cabinet to approve the recommendation
presented today
foreign
of the draft investment plan which is
attached at appendix a to note the
consultation process underway
excuse me that will inform the final
investment plan which is attached at
appendix B to agree delegation to the
assistant director of foreign economy
and regeneration in consultation with
the portfolio holders for economic
development and communities to finalize
the investment plan prior to the
submission to the government
and I'd beg your pardon but I have lost
the number
fairies
here we go
so I asked the cabinet to endorse MC
a 22 13.
on this agenda agenda item 16 and I
would ask for a second to please
thank you very much councilor Fatman uh
councilor Brewster thank you
sorry thank you very much chair
um
yes I'm very happy to Second this one
but I also note that we haven't got the
director or the corporate manager in the
room and I think they probably are
instrumental in needing in being there
I think
[Music]
okay thank you very much councilor
booster what I suggest we do in that
case um if members feel that it's
necessary to have offices present for
this item is I suggest we adjourn for 15
minutes and see if we can get the
officers uh present for the for this
agenda item so we'll uh pause the
meeting here and if I could ask for
members and officers to be back here at
11 55 please thank you very much
foreign
good morning everyone and welcome back
to this meeting of mid-suffolk District
Council cabinet we are resuming uh item
16 paper MCA 20 22 13 at the UK shared
Prosperity fund uh we have councilor
flatland proposing the recommendations
in the report and Council Brewster
seconding I'll now move on to questions
from cabinet members are there any
questions from members
councilor Whitehead
um yeah I mean outside of any briefing I
spoke to the director director about the
fact that um
does this investment plan that submitted
can roll three years or do we submit
three plans over the three years and I
was surprised that we the government
requires to put our
three-year program in by the first of
August because the 64 of the spend is in
year three 24 cents in year two and only
12 cents in year one and yet we're
supposed to finalize plan by the first
of OCT first of August and it seems to
me that if we come up with ideas for
leveling up for year three which are
really valid ones it's frustrating we'd
have to wait for year three to to
implement them I suspect we'd probably
want to go to our growth efficiency fund
and so I'm quite frustrated with the
government in terms of how they've how
they've done this process and required
us to finalize our plans from the first
of August
foreign
yes when we had our um our meeting with
um
uh with um
Fiona on this
um
it it you know it was lastminute.com if
you like we've been thrown into looking
for
um you know projects that are going to
be very valuable in very short time to
get all this work together
um and I'm hoping she's going to walk
through the door any minute now okay oh
lovely can I pass that over to you
nothing excellent thank you thank you
council department if I could invite the
corporate manager for cleaning business
to comment please thank you
oh thank you yes and apologies from
Fiona um because of the timetable of the
cabinet she was hoping to be here as
well
um in terms of the time
um we are looking at a first of August
deadline for submission of a three-year
investment plan however what government
has suggested is that the year one needs
to be detailed plans year two and three
can be indicative so what we are
expected to provide are broad outlines
of the types of projects that we think
that we will deliver across years two
and three
um but because we're already at
thing
we're expected to provide much more
detail
in the delivery of the projects within
this current year
a more broad information about the
Thematic programs
that we will deliver against in years
two and three
expectation that we will work alongside
other Suffolk authorities for primarily
the educational skills programs in year
three but also looking at some of the
business support programs in year two
and year three so what government are
expecting is not a full program plan for
every project for every penny of the
three-year investment plan what they
is
comes and output
output for the type of types of jobs
that we'll create the number of programs
will run the number of people put
through
um specific investment or or training
programs the number of business
supported by by schemes the number of
young people that we will help through
training programs for example rather
than saying we will spend two hundred
thousand right on this project in year
three
thank you
thank you very much are there any other
questions from cabinet
questions from other members present
in that case I would like to open the
item Up For Debate does any Cabinet
member wish to debate this item
it's Council flattman
yeah well I'd just like to say that you
know we
I'd like to thank the officers for
rallying around this because you know at
this very last minute we already have
our five million spend that we're
looking at and working on and then to
have this
like thrown in it
at the last minute you know no one wants
to turn money down so obviously we're
going to do our absolute best to make
sure we we are in line to get this um
this extra money
um which we can use to very you know use
um definitely to um
expand on other projects that we and
some of these things we already had in
the pipeline anyway so in a way that's
come
can't
we can't put the gift horse in the mouth
we're gonna have to you
you know to the very best of our
abilities and and yes thank you to
Fiona's team
um for all the work they've been doing
around this and um you know it is what
it is and we we must use it to our very
best Advantage thanks
thank you very much councilor flatman uh
if no other member of cabinet wishes to
debate this item then I suggest we move
on to the vote which is on the three
recommendations uh in our paper
share of hands for all those in favor
please
that is unanimous
thank you very much moving then finally
on to item 18 paper MCA slash 22-5 the
confidential minute of the mid-suffic
cabinet meeting held on Monday the 6th
of June 2022 this minute is confidential
so if members wish to discuss the minute
the meeting will need to go into a
closed session uh
will be taken on in an open session
however does any member wish to discuss
the details of the minute
no in that case I can propose uh we will
and first in the first instance could I
have a proposal please
councilor Gould thank you and a seconder
councilor Whitehead thank you very much
uh in that case uh we will now uh go to
the vote in which case could I have a
show of hands for all those in favor
please
thank you very much that is again uh
lovely that brings us to the end of our
agenda today uh the date of the time of
the next uh meeting is scheduled for
Monday the 5th of September uh 10 30 am
thank you very much for attending and I
will now close this meeting good
afternoon